[Music]
hey i'm dave klein and i'm jordan may
and we had a chance to check out sonic
frontiers at summer game fest 2022 and
we're here to talk about it so jordan
initial impressions what did you think
it's
wild that sonic is being put in an
open breath of the wild type world is
kind of like my initial impressions of
it i it's one of those things that like
in a follow-up interview and we're
talking to the devs and whatnot they're
like oh this is going to be like a
new step for sonic and i and i can see
that i can see that this could
theoretically be like a transformative
step for our favorite blue hedgehog but
i'm not entirely convinced that it's
that it works
like that it works the way that they
want it to work yeah i mean it's also
interesting with what you said with
breath of the wild because in that
interview that jordan did uh they
revealed that they started working on in
2017 yeah same release day as breath of
the wild so it seems like a pretty clear
inspiration
yeah i feel like some things do work
because we both had a chance to play it
and some things don't and the last sonic
game that i played that was a newer one
was sonic forces and for me it has some
of the same issues which is the game
feel of it
i i like what they're doing with the
size of the levels i like there's a lot
of collecting in the game
which i like the openness is actually
refreshing with the fact that sonic is
controls a little weird so you're not
going to fall off that much
but to me it's just controlling sonic
just feels slightly off and anytime you
move a direction he just shoots that
direction
and you're just going to start flying in
different directions and that's where
the opening field kind of helps
but it still has that same issue where
something about just feels a little off
to me yeah and we should clarify both
dave and i played there's two modes for
this game one where it's like oh
sonic controls a little bit more it's
like it's action mode and then the one
that's like high speed mode where he
goes apparently blazing fast we both
played on that mode that's a good point
yeah yeah it's possible that on the
other mode it's much easier to do the
actual platforming and combat segments
yeah i mean we only had 15 minutes each
yeah um actually something that's worth
mentioning that you brought up is that
as we talk to the producer about the
game with there's kind of different
segments within the game and like things
that they focused on and one was the
open field another one is the combat
that's completely different than
anything we've seen in sonic so far
which is that now he punches and kicks
and you have a full combat sequence
where you can
learn different moves there's almost
like a skill tree for someone to learn
moves and
uh there's dodging now and you're really
getting an enemy's faces as opposed to
just bashing them which was an
interesting direction to take sonic in i
bet they did did you like the combat at
all like i actually you know what i
i did like it i think it didn't feel as
refined and again that's sort of the
game feel thing to me where things feel
just slightly off there's mini bosses
that you face in the game and a lot of
them that they were we were facing
feel really built in for the mechanics
like there is a giant one that both of
us fought that has these legs that slams
down and then you run up the legs to
jump and then then start attacking it
and the shadow of the colossus yeah very
very shadow of the colossus and i felt
like they were really taking into
account the mechanics of the game and
the gameplay and the combats and how
sonic works for these enemies so i
appreciated that but did you get a
different takeaway let's say yeah with
those bosses the ones that were the like
larger than life that they were almost
like platforming challenges in and of
themselves like that sort of combat i
did really enjoy because i think that
kind of fits with like the core idea and
conceit of sonic where it's like he is a
action platformer like protagonist yeah
we did face like a mini boss called the
ninja that it was more like oh no this
is kind of like just getting in its face
and like dodging and then like punching
it in the back and i'm like wow this is
a that that didn't really work for me as
well i was not enjoying that as much so
i i do really like the like the ones
that you were talking about the ones
where it's like oh i am platforming and
fighting like at the same time it gave
me very shadow of the colossus hyper
light drifter like those sort of vibes
and i think that works for sonic so my
hope is that we see
more of those uh throughout the game
there was like that boss fight where
it's like oh you had to like circle
around and to like slowly knock down his
head so that you could actually like uh
attack him and finish him off i'm like
that was really cool i did enjoy that
but man that ninja boss fight yes no
honestly the ninja boss fight again
feels very breath of the wild inspired
to me because
um that whole like dodge you gets a
little slow time to hit the enemy a
little bit
is what breath of the wild did so it
feels like again it pulled away from
that i also love that that boss you're
talking about there's one where you use
a special move by circling around it to
stun it that was another one that i
liked because it uses the mechanics but
his name is just tower so i thought that
was kind of funny i'm like oh okay tower
that's
that's the boss all right tower although
i do wonder and we should talk a little
bit about like the story or i guess lack
of story that we really saw with this
this idea that's like oh it's just it's
just ninja it's just tower like we saw
these items that it's like oh if you
collect enough of these you can save amy
it's like save amy like what's happened
to amy and then we had a cut scene where
it's like we saw eggman but he was in a
totally different place so it was like
it was just mostly
sonic not knowing what was going on so
we the players didn't know what was
going on we're just kind of
wandering around and the devs were like
oh it's supposed to be a bit more of a
mystery this time around like it's not
like this action comedy of sonic being
like eggman's here shadow's here like we
need to stop him like there's a mystery
here that you have to solve and i am
curious to see like is that the thing
that sells sonic frontiers the fact that
there is a mystery at the core of this
game that you have to try to solve
something that we've never had before
i'm curious to try sherlock sonic
uh something else too is that what we
played was essentially like the plateau
and breath of the wild where it's this
smaller segment and then it opens up
into the open field thing how did you
feel about the open field platforming
itself because there's also a lot of
puzzles sprinkled throughout it too
there's a lot to do in the open field
it's fine
like so enthusiastic well yeah i mean
it's one of those things where it's like
we we've had breath of the wild we've
had immortals phoenix rising we've had
uh the horizon forbidden west we've had
a bunch of open world games that have
puzzles in them over the past year i
don't think sonic does anything actually
revolutionary with them in its open
world besides the fact that everything's
a bit further spaced out because sonic
runs so fast he's basically already the
mount that you would unlock for like
right link and alloy and stuff like that
so that
is i'm not going to be like oh yeah the
puzzle's like this that's going to sell
the game i think it's just kind of your
elementary like open world puzzles i'm
cautiously optimistic about it i'm not
like totally sold on it but it is
something that i'm like oh when it comes
out i'll probably check it out yeah
honestly i think it's for me one of the
my favorite sonic games i've seen in the
past
10 years outside of maybe generations
honestly though like not oh i know i
know but it's like it's one where i it
looks like it's a step in the right
direction i'm mainly concerned about the
game feel of it but
a lot of the things they're doing i
think are steps in the right direction
so i'm really hopeful and yeah so that
was sonic frontiers um
looking forward to it hopefully it will
be what all of us sonic fans really hope
for so
i'm hoping for that yeah until then
that's it for us with sonic frontiers
and summer game fest stay tuned for more
summer game fest and we'll see you guys
later bye
you